Mario to me Mario
what who lets ago okie-dokie oh I've
been the voice of Mario for 26 years now
Borgata we do hi I'm Charles Martin a I
do the voice of Super Mario Luigi
nevermind haha Mario hey buddy
yeah oh you're gonna eat that garlic and
I was even Donkey Kong one boy oh I am
an actor and voice actor I did gosh 25
years of theater corporate videos
circuitry and semiconductor processes a
few film and television products now
beat it all you know and then that I had
the marvelous beginning of becoming a
voice actor and that's how I started
with E to me Mario Mario was first
created in 1981 in a game called Donkey
Kong as it got refined through the years
it became Mario and Princess Peach the
PTAs and I came along in 1990 I actually
crashed an audition because I was
catching them as I walked in they were
walking out finished for the day
I said can I read for this and the guy
looked at his watch and goes all right
come on in you're an Italian plumber
from Brooklyn a character in a video
game for Nintendo called Mario so make
up a voice make up a video game start
talking and I thought to myself video
game I don't know anything about video
games and all of a sudden I hear action
I go hello I'm a Mario let's make a
pizza by together you will get something
sausage I'll get some spaghetti Lee puts
forgetting the sausage in the pizza and
he said you know cut stop talking
there's no more tape all right thanks
we'll be in touch and I thought that was
you know ok there's the door we'll see
you later and I he calls Nintendo I
found out Mario I got him and that was
26 amazing fantastic years ago
I know hello me oh look at this or the
character for me brings out the best in
me and so I love that I love sharing
things too I go to meet Mario fans and I
hear the most wonderful thing you know
the you're the voice of my childhood you
know I used to play with my dad now I'm
playing with my kids you know and we
just it's a way our family comes
together back the memories yeah you just
have fun you know that's my mantra for
life come on let's go
it's have more fun bye bye see you in my
Games's what who
you